[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show um one of the
meta stories that has been getting some
attention over the last few days is the
story about the media coverage of
the disappearance of 22 year old gabby
petito now if you've not covered the
story or if you've not followed the
story i don't know how many of you are
covering stories on shows but it maybe
some of you are if you've not followed
the story
gabby petito was a 22 year old
um
sort of influencer i mean she had a
presence online
and she um disappeared and subsequently
was found dead
and now her
partner brian laundry as of this moment
is missing people don't we don't know
where he is
there are questions as to whether he's
responsible for her disappearance and
sort of at the center of all of this is
that there's now police traffic cam
video that was from august 12th which
was posted to our youtube channel
where police in utah stopped her and her
partner
she was crying
um
ultimately although she was almost
arrested for domestic violence police
ended up making the call not to arrest
anybody and just say you guys have to
separate for the night
if indeed the partner is the one
responsible for her death there is
speculation that hey if the officers had
actually gone by the letter of the law
and arrested her for domestic violence
she might be alive today it's all very
very speculative so that's the story
the media metapiece is
that her disappearance as a young blonde
white woman
gets disproportionately more attention
than when there are similar situations
involving other
people with different characteristics
and this was sort of asserted generally
by joyride on msnbc in a way that some
people didn't like okay
but there's a newsweek article which
says that 400 indigenous women went
missing over the last decade in the same
state as gabby petito in in they were
originally reported missing in wyoming
um and really they don't get the
coverage i mean the the the proof is in
the pudding so to speak and that those
stories have not gotten the coverage of
the gabby potito case
now
10 years is a long time 10 years ago and
eight years ago media has changed but
it's a pretty good case that's being
made pat that yes this is being handled
differently now whether it's because of
race or because this is an influencer or
whatever
or because there's traffic cam video i
mean that's another aspect of this that
makes it more salacious and interesting
we'd have to kind of parse out each of
those explanations but there's
definitely something here
yes and the term for this is missing
white woman syndrome right
and you know it could be a number of
factors like you're pointing out i tried
to check out her youtube channel and it
really wasn't that big before this story
blew up no uh maybe she has some
presence on other social media platforms
instagram i guess she was a blogger okay
instagram yeah so that does make sense
and of course the couple was doing van
life so you know i understand if it's
a celebrity or a pseudo celebrity then
they're going to get more attention than
the average person out there but i think
part of it does have to do with the look
the fact that she was a pretty young
white woman and
she went missing and it seems to have
been that she was murdered and we don't
know where the murderer is now the
alleged murderer um and you know there's
a number of different factors here but i
do think that you know if you just
change some of the factors here like if
it was a man instead or if it was a
black woman instead or indigenous woman
instead then this probably wouldn't get
the same media coverage even if that
person did have the same sort of social
media presence but you know you never
really have these one-to-one comparisons
so no
i mean i think without a doubt if this
had been
a
65-year-old black woman it gets less
coverage like i think there's no
question whatsoever
if it's a 20-year 22 year old
young black woman
with a sort of similar presence online i
i'm not sure i think there's still a
difference in some set but i think it
would be less disparate i mean i i
sometimes watch these like true story
crime shows and they can be captivating
right when you see these reenactments
and sometimes there's these twists and
turns and you don't know where it's
going i don't really see that with this
case and you know i'm not trying to like
undermine it or play into like the
salaciousness of all of this but like it
seems a little bit straightforward to me
what happened and of course the
investigation is going to go underway
now what do you think you think the part
the fiancee killed her i mean that that
seems to be what the evidence is
pointing to yeah especially because he's
not cooperating with authorities well
but he's missing isn't it possible they
were both killed
well he dropped off the van at his
florida residence alone oh okay though
that okay so yeah i haven't even been
following it okay okay yeah so i mean i
think it's pretty straightforward and
like there's this manhunt going on for
this guy and hopefully they find him
soon and if he is the one who is
responsible for the him the death and
you know that they hold him accountable
and everything like that but like it
just seems a little bit straightforward
it doesn't seem to me like one of these
like murder mystery stories like some of
these other stories uh get attention for
so that's why to me it's a little bit
striking like i don't really understand
the appeal of it all that much you know
one of the things
there's a there's a meta meta story here
as well which is some of the media
outlets
reporting that this story gets more
attention because the victim is white
aren't regularly reporting about the
missing indigenous women either right
like that's the meta meta story which is
great you've identified so you've got
media coverage you then have media
coverage which identifies that the media
coverage may partially hinge on the race
of the victim
but they're not covering the missing
black women and the missing indigenous
women either so maybe that's something
they could do as well they're just as
much deserving of the criticism that
they're loving that makes a lot of sense
too uh the fact is you can't talk about
every single one of these stories like
you know newsweek reported that out of
wyoming there was 466 indigenous women
over the past 10 years yeah if you were
to write up articles about every single
one of those cases and you expanded it
beyond wyoming and the entire united
states that would be all you were
talking about so i understand you can't
do it every time right i mean it's a 466
over 120 months is a story it's
essentially a story a week right i mean
that that's what you you'd be writing
about it every single week and of course
you can't do that um you know maybe you
can have like a little newspaper
clipping but it's not going to be
frontline news it's not going to be this
thing that everyone pays attention to
and so you have to sort of pick and
choose when these stories really do blow
up and i suppose like you know maybe if
it's a person who's particularly
influential like has a big social media
presence then that's the time you go
talk about it or maybe if it's like a
particularly callous murder or if it's
really mysterious the circumstances
that's when you talk about it but like i
i do notice the trend here that we only
seem to really talk about these stories
when it's
the person who's a suspect or the person
who is um the victim it fits a certain
demographic we can say sometimes i
wonder if i went missing like at my
level of notoriety which is like within
our circle of like left tube you know
we're one of the biggest channels but
most people have no idea who i am like
how how much coverage if any if it was
like a suspicious me being missing how
much coverage would there be i really
have no idea i think it really depends
on the circumstances and whether maybe
one of our rivals was suspected of being
responsible i think that could get some
attention
and surely enough i would be posting
updates to the youtube channel every
single day saying where is david right
because i don't want to be unemployed
and if you go missing and especially
under mysterious circumstances yeah my
employment and the future of my work
will be put into question so i don't
want that to happen for sure yeah no so
you would have to provide daily updates
on that um all right well anyway it's it
there's there are multiple interesting
media related stories and uh as far as
what happened
you know the first step is finding brian
laundry and figuring out what if any his
involvement was we've talked before
about mitt romney's
ira
and like how the hell did mitt romney
end up with so much money in his ira
when in theory
you are limited in how much money you
can contribute to an ira and there is a
mechanism which allows this
which the house bill currently under
proposal would eliminate okay
legislation making its way through
congress right now
would do away with the
ability to build up these massive
amounts of tax-free money by the ultra
wealthy this is part of the package
proposed by democrats it targets these
iras specifically propublica has been
reporting about them
and those accounts have allowed some
super wealthy americans to turn their
roth iras which are really a tool meant
for middle-class retirement savings
tax-free middle-class retirement savings
into a massive tax shelter richard neal
from massachusetts one of the first
members of congress we ever interviewed
on the show actually
would cap how much you can hold in a
roth to 20 million dollars and it would
compel the holders of these accounts to
regularly withdraw anything over that
limit
separately individuals would have to add
up the balances of all retirement
accounts including roths traditional
iras 401ks and 403bs and every year
withdraw half of anything over 10
million dollars and it would only apply
to people making over 400 000 a year so
this would really this really would only
target the very rich it doesn't it would
not affect anybody earning under 400k a
year
and it would not affect people uh with
under
10 million dollars or 20 million dollars
depending on these two different
scenarios in their combined accounts
this seems logical to me like the the
spirit of the roth ira was not for
people like peter thiel and mitt romney
to accumulate this amount of money in
that account they can accumulate this
amount of money but it's got to be in a
taxable account yeah exactly it's the
the intention of the roth ira from its
beginning was the idea that lower and
middle class people could be encouraged
to save for retirement because when you
collect that money when you turn 59 and
a half you can get it all tax-free you
don't have to pay taxes on the capital
gains
this bill would also target the backdoor
roth ira contributions because there's
this loophole where you can put money
into a traditional ira and then roll it
over to a roth ira and then you don't
have to worry about because i guess if
you make over i think it's 125 000 a
year you can't contribute directly to a
roth uh but there's this loophole where
if you put it in the traditional first
and then roll it over to the roth then
you're a-okay and i think the way it
works is in the first place that's not
if i understand correctly
if you do that when you contribute to a
traditional if i remember correctly a
traditional ira you contribute and your
contributions are tax-deductible so you
you you don't pay tax on the
contributions but then you pay tax on
what you take out of it including the
gains that you have made
the roth is post-tax money
that grows tax-free and when you take it
out you don't pay taxes so when you do
the conversion remember the traditional
you've already deducted from your taxes
when you contributed you've got to pay
the taxes when you do the conversion
that you would have paid but then it
grows tax-free and you can you can
withdraw tax-free so if you can do big
amounts of it strategically it's a big
boon potentially to people that time the
move at an at a convenient time yep and
that's why we hear about stories like
peter thiel who was able to grow his
roth ira into about five billion dollars
in all these loopholes the thing about
this tax plan at least when it comes to
uh getting rid of the backdoor roth ira
is that uh it wouldn't take effect until
2031 which
to me sounds like it'll never happen
right because between now and then we'll
probably have a republican president
with the republican-controlled senate
and congress and that'll probably be the
first thing on their agenda to get rid
of and we probably will have you know
different party control at some point
between now and then and we know that
republicans whenever they're in control
like to pass a new tax bill that
happened under bush it happened under
trump and so this is probably the type
of thing that they would get rid of
right away and part of the reason why
it would arguably be less effective to
have it start in such a long time is you
provide a long period of time for people
to find other ways to shelter money from
taxation and uh
you know we'll see what happens but with
that timeline
the effectiveness that
at actually capturing what it's trying
to capture
is certainly going to be diminished so
we'll continue to cover it and many
things have been proposed we'll see
which of these things actually pass
amazon is now lobbying the us government
to legalize cannabis
they announced this yesterday the
company stopped pre-employment drug
testing
they support national legalization
and part of this seems to be just
self-interest the amazon warehouse
employees have famously high turnover
believed to be in part because of
terrible conditions
and the idea is a national legalization
could help with hiring
they say given our previous support for
legalizing cannabis federally and
expunging certain criminal records
uh we support this we've started to
lobby the marijuana opportunity
reinvestment and expungement act of 2021
called the more act
um
both there's also another bill called
the cannabis administration and
opportunity act both would remove
cannabis from being schedule one drugs
that is the same schedule that includes
lsd and heroin most reasonable people
would agree
cannabis does not belong on the same
list as lsd and heroin and it would
enable some level of national
legalization they first announced
support for this back in june
and um is is this sort of like the 15
minimum wage to you pat where it's like
they've calculated the pr or bottom line
benefit to them and so that's what this
is motivated by i don't know if it's
entirely pr it just could be one of
those things where it would help them
with higher energy no i mean both yeah
one one or the other or both i mean
there's probably some benefit to it
because i have to imagine to this point
the vast majority of people in the
united states want to see marijuana
legalized and so yeah amazon is finally
coming around to it although it seems a
little bit of a johnny come lately story
like if they had made this announcement
in 2005 or 2010 then maybe we could sort
of get behind them and be like oh wow
they're really out in front of this
they're doing something that's not very
popular but at this point it's just like
okay well yeah i mean so many people
already want cannabis to be legalized
anyway yeah if you legalize it at the
federal level or you know remove it from
that schedule one list you'd still have
to deal with state laws anyway so you'd
still have uh these these barriers and
so you know it's it's somewhat
interesting i guess we can say and it's
the part of the long string of stories
that have come out from amazon lately
trying to get them positive pr like now
they're putting more into education
funds right um and you know i guess it's
it's somewhat good right but how much
credit can we actually give them what i
don't understand is how would it
actually make hiring easier because if
they want to stop pre-employment drug
screening
i don't fully get why this would
actually really make hiring easier for
them other than maybe people would be
more willing to apply
i i'm just not really sure i don't
really know i don't understand that
detail maybe people who suspect that
they wouldn't be able to get a job with
amazon because they have a marijuana
charge on their record you would not any
longer feel that i see a quote here from
amazon senior vp of human resources beth
gilletti who said quote we've found that
eliminating pre-employment testing for
cannabis allows us to expand our
applicant pool yeah but that has to do
with amazon specifically not necessarily
other companies so you know maybe
they're just finding that like this is
what we have concluded based on the fact
that we no longer care about marijuana
presence in our employees and the people
that we're hiring from so if we
recommend this to the government if we
recommend this to other businesses then
maybe that can be a good thing overall
maybe it may be that it may be that
simple yeah um of course i agree with
this but as pat is pointing out
this is not super edgy at this point in
time you know uh and so we'll see what
happens with it i do think cannabis
absolutely needs to be rescheduled that
would not make it
recreationally legal in all states as
pat is pointing out but all of we
welcome all of these steps i'm i'm open
to this as long as we keep making steps
i don't care that much about the order
that the steps take place in totally
yeah i mean if amazon came out and said
we support legalization of psychedelics
yes magic mushrooms and lsd sure then
maybe we'd be like oh wow that's edgy
yeah yeah really ahead of the curve here
totally that's not what we're seeing it
is not at all what we're seeing uh so
we'll follow it if you think there's
some other reason that amazon is not
admitting to for why they want to
legalize cannabis or want cannabis to be
legalized
uh let us know and we will follow up on
it and otherwise i will see everybody
back here tomorrow